[Music]
you have a recommendation then if you're
in the household right now and you're
any of these ages let's say you're 25
you're 58 and you're 80 let's just go
with those three ages and you're not
feeling great
should you be then trying to go to the
hospital or I guess maybe if you're 80
you are or just stay home and deal with
it the best again yeah in general so in
general one of the things we all need to
be very good about doing right now is
giving our healthcare workers a break so
you should not be going to the hospital
with the sniffles right now there are
few things that Americans should do you
should get a flu shot one of the reasons
you should get a flu shot is not because
the flu shot has it prevents you from
getting coronavirus it does not but if
you get a flu shot it lowers your risk
of actually getting the flu and
therefore you won't go to the hospital
with the flu and now is not a good time
for you to be burden in our health care
system for your own sake or for the sake
of the system furthermore going to the
hospital if you're not actually sick if
there a lot of actually or if you're
just mildly sick there are a lot of
actually seriously sick people there you
might get the germ from them so it's not
like in a hospital waiting room is not a
time to be right now if you unless you
actually need it so generally speaking
the symptoms of coronavirus are variable
you should have a fever above 101.5
it's in about 85% of people not everyone
but most people have a fever a dry cough
would be a symptom and then there's a
shortness of breath certainly if you
have shortness of breath and a fever
absolutely you should go to the hospital
and then there's a whole host of other
symptoms at lower percentages so if
you're a 25 year old person and you know
you have a runny nose and low-grade
temperature and some muscle aches it's
probably not coronavirus stay home until
you get sicker that would be a
reasonable choice you know if you're an
older person then you should have a
lower threshold and ideally if you went
we would test you right and but again we
don't have enough testing yet we're
hopefully the country will get better at
that in the coming months have run we're
obviously in some unchartered territory
with coronavirus and our plan here is to
help you make as much sense of the
situation in
alarmist fashion is possible if you're
looking for reliable information from
experts on the front lines of the
pandemic check out our coronavirus
playlist which will keep adding updates
- right over here and to get notified of
all future videos be sure to subscribe